as you get older if you have
any kernel of wisdom you stop competing
with other people and you just realize
you're here
to find the truest expression of your
heart
that you can share with the
world you say with the fans give them
kind of what they want at the heart of
the story but then open the world wider
is that sort of like you know the saying
i know you better than you know yourself
which exactly because because
as i said earlier i'm i'm the same as my
audience so if i'm enthusiastic about
what i'm working on if i find a story
that interests me
i'll be able to tell a story i think
that my audience will like i never worry
first of all i never talk down to them i
never worry about what will please them
i'm just trying to tell a story that i
think is meaningful that meaningful from
a character standpoint um for instance
and i'm always writing about things that
i'm either um
you know love or frustrated about or
want to comment on but always it's
through the characters if the characters
don't work none of it works and um
i'll give you an example i came up with
this idea called the show runners
network where i'm creating six science
fiction horror and fantasy series
with six major show runners so it's
rocknell bannon who created farscape and
defiance and seaquest and alien nation
and cult he's now ep on evil
another
partnership i have on another one of the
shows with mark ferguson hawk ostby who
created and we're show runners on the
expanse and also did iron man and
children of men and so and then one of
them is a rod sterling project as well
and
so
so when i started this project i sat
down and i wrote up 200 ideas for tv
shows
and uh
and so every day i'd come up with 10
ideas and just write them down no
censorship at all
and uh and so then rock rock no bannon
and i went down that list and and we saw
what sparked for both of us
and something a pet peeve of mine
is you know
now there's certain kinds of black
stereotypes you can't have on tv or
latino stereotypes or you know
misogynistic things right but older
actors
either are playing coming down with
cancer coming down with dementia or the
funny grandpa or the funny grandma
and the seniors i know in my life and
the seniors that i i'm one of them now
um
these are vital involved engaged people
they are not those stereotypes and so i
was very frustrated with that so i came
up with an idea for a show called sweet
haven and ironically i came off this
before the pandemic and the basic notion
is a a bioengineered disease gets out of
hand and kills everyone in the world
under 60. and so the people 60 and above
have to figure out how to keep humanity
going when they can't reproduce
and so it's a very fun idea so rock and
i worked up the plot line and elaine and
i wrote the pilot script from the
outline that rock and i had worked up
and then we cast it and it has robert
picardo from
you know star trek voyager and it's got
barbara bain from space 1999 and it's
got gates mcfadden from star trek the
next generation and mike harney from
orange is the new black and on and on is
this amazing veronica cartwright from
alien and the birds you know amazing
amazing cast and uh
and and they play these very interesting
and active characters james hong from
blade runners ended in big trouble
little in china but they are not going
to be playing the stereotypes they're
going to be playing fully rounded people
in that world
and so we've done two table reads via
zoom and we're going to shoot in the
near future so um but again it's just
i was excited about that idea and uh
lovely thing when you can raise money is
that you don't have to worry about oh is
this something the networks would buy i
don't care frankly i mean if they buy it
great it makes my life easier it gives
me more money to play with but
i don't at this stage of my life i don't
need approval i need
uh i need to be effective
so um it's a very different energy
the wonderful thing is as if you've
succeeded as you get older if you have
any kernel of wisdom you stop competing
with other people and you just realize
you're here to find the truest
expression of your heart
that you can share with the world
and if people are moved by what you
create if they are um
made better in some way even you know
entertainment is not it's not something
to uh
to dismiss it's an important thing um
you've succeeded you know i mean every
day i'm just trying to be uh the best
version of myself and be open to i i
love collaboration i l the actors are my
collaborators the the designers are my
collaborators everyone and and even
today when elaine and i you know i
direct with elaine because elaine is a
better director than i am and she's an
actor's director she was a trained she
was an actress and a director off
broadway and
i'm an okay director i'm good visually
but um
but when elaine and i direct together
it's better it's better the work is
better the out the uh what comes out is
better and but what that allows me to do
for instance today we were looking at
sets and getting ready to shoot some
scenes we're going to shoot in a few
weeks and elaine was
her vision was different from mine in
terms of how many
people we have in this scene or how many
extras or and she wanted it few or fewer
tighter on the focus on the scene and so
i had to step back from what i was
attached to
my way of doing it my design in my head
i see the shots in my head
and say well let's let's let's see what
she has to say let's see what where
she's going with this let's see if it
works and that's a good
healthy creative instinct because it
lets in
the possibility of something better
and and because i'm not threatened
at all
um just grateful i can do that and so
when you stop
trying to
be
there's you're not in a race
you know
you're not trying to to beat anybody
else you're just telling a story you're
just sharing
something that you love with other
people you know and
i was thinking about an interesting
uh analogy
yesterday where uh i heard someone
talking about quilting they made a quilt
for survivors of the people who died in
9 11 in the family and and i thought you
know it's funny no one ever talks about
pitching a quilt you don't go and meet
with a whole bunch of executives and say
hey i have an idea for a quilt and you
spend years just telling the idea of
what you have the idea you have for a
quilt and you never actually make a
quilt people would think you were out of
your mind right the point of
quilting is to make quilts and share
them with others
but writers in in tv and film they think
that that's an appropriate way to spend
their their lives to endlessly be
pitching and well i pitched this and it
didn't sell i pitched that and it didn't
sell it's like why don't you just
make it make the thing you know get get
people together make make the work then
you're making the the the quilt you're
quilting you're not talking about a
quilt someday you may get to make and uh
you know it's it's so much more
rewarding and uh
you know it's uh
i'm you know i'm just uh
i've got my feet planted on the ground
and and my head in the clouds
you know it's like
elaine keeps keeps my feet on the ground
but
but there's such a lovely feeling of
accomplishment
when
you do something and it comes out the
way you want it and it goes out into the
world and people love it i mean even on
mr scifi we put out the first hour of
space command it's been seen by millions
of people that have got 97 thumbs up
well that's great you know it's great to
have that it means that the people
really liked it and and uh
you know that that helps make me uh
eager for the next day and eager for the
next script
were you always this way where you just
wanted to do something that meant
something to you that you were excited
by and you were staying in your own
metaphorical lane no
no i i was at the beginning of my career
you know i was very i i there was no no
certainty that i would make it and there
was always this
i mean i was very lucky because i i
started working writing my first book at
21 i sold my first short story at 19 and
i was running for tv by the time i was
22 or 23
and over the next 20 years the longest
period in that entire 20 years that i
was out of work was three months
and so i earned millions of dollars i
worked for all the major studios and
networks but
but there was always sense that it could
stop abruptly and it actually did at one
point and i had to figure out a way of
reinventing and re a way of
getting things going again and
fortunately i was open to
new ways of doing things i i was very
open to that and so that's allowed me to
be where i am now but um
but i was not secure by any means i was
i was driven by a creative vision
and i loved writing other characters i
loved writing whether it was spock kirk
mccoy or whether it was the characters
in friday the 13th series or even the
smurfs whomever it was really fun to
write through those characters right you
know write what i wanted to say through
those those characters you have to be if
i can hear the voice of a character i
can write him you know i have to be able
to hear the voice but um
but i
i was never that secure i was never that
certain that everything was just gonna
cost along so i never felt like i could
just like take my hands off the wheel
um
going back what i probably would have
done some things differently my my
priority was always i always felt that
my obligation cr my creative obligation
was to my audience but i often didn't
take care of my bosses as well as i
might have you know i wasn't
i wasn't a worker among workers in a way
that i should have been and it's
fortunately i still was able to create a
body of work but
if i if i could go back and change one
thing i would be much more
um
taking care of people in that way and uh
i've never been a political animal you
know i don't care about those things and
i have worked with people who were
and i've also lost jobs to people who
were like one friend of mine was
recommending me to be a producer on this
show that he was creating
and
the producer who was running the show
didn't hire me and ultimately found out
what he was doing was he was only hiring
people who were his troops so he could
even eventually fire my friend because
he was political animal and
and but at the time i thought oh i
somehow said something wrong in the
interview no there was no way i was
going to get that job
but and my friend ended up out on his
ass you know and uh and that's when we
realized what it was all about but um
but i think i could have taken care of
people better you know and uh
i don't regret
in terms of the work i don't regret any
of the work i've done but but that's a
lesson that would have been good to have
learned sooner
yeah some people aren't good at playing
to politics no and i don't like kissing
the ass of people who are mediocre i
mean my the one thing that really
you know i was very open to people's
you know humanity but
i could never stand anyone who just said
well
it doesn't have to be great it doesn't
have to be good you know it's like we're
just here to make sausage i could i
could never never never stand that it's
like well you may be but i'm not i'm
here to make something wonderful that'll
last the test of time you either stand
the test of time i i'm you know
i remember one time on sliders we were
someone pitched a clone story
and i said to my boss
that story has been done on every other
show
every other science fiction show
and i was saying we shouldn't buy it and
he said well no but it hasn't been done
on our show and i said yes but the
audience isn't just watching our show
and the irony was that they bought that
script and i had to rewrite it you know
i rewrote and made it as good as i could
and but the thing was it's like had i
been making the choice of what we bought
or what we didn't buy i wouldn't bought
that because it was cliche already then
it was cliche and i had to fight that
cliche when i rewrote it to find some
meaning in it but
but
it was a radically different philosophy
of how to make television because i know
from my own experience that a single
hour of television can change someone's
life forever for the better it's a huge
responsibility and i never never
duck that responsibility i'm very
cognizant of it
you